want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get the seven best
lessons from elon musk jeff bezos bill
gates and other billionaire
entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one pay attention to the details
with elon musk
you want to make something beautiful i
mean
that you want to
trigger whatever
fundamental aesthetic algorithms are
like like in your brain there's
you have i think some intrinsic
uh
elements that that represent beauty um
and
and that that trigger
the emotion of appreciation of beauty in
in your your mind
um
and i think that these are
these are actually relatively
consistent among people i mean not not
completely um some people like not
everyone likes the same thing but there
are there's a lot of commonality but i
think it is important to con to combine
aesthetic design with functionality like
the thing that's like if you say like
what was really hard about say the model
s or the model x
um was to
combine aesthetics and
utility
so to balance the two
you can make a car look very good by
giving it
sort of
certain proportions like making it sort
of low and slim
and and
but
if you uh if you do that the utility is
significantly affected to make a sports
car look good is relatively easy
but to make a sedan look good or an suv
look good is quite difficult really pay
attention to the little details
the
the nuances of of design and shape and
form function and
um
that you know just the way it looks in
different lights and when something's
off the little thing how do you
experience that
it drives me bananas
yeah
um i mean it's and it does the problem
is like if you
you can train yourself to to pay
attention to the tiny details i think
almost anyone can
um
although it it this is a very much
double-edged sword because then you see
all the little details
and then little things drive you crazy
so
but like most people don't they don't
see they don't consciously see the small
details but they
they do subconsciously see them like you
you sort of your mind takes in a result
of the overall
you know
an overall impression
and and you you know if something is
appealing or not even though you may not
be able to point out exactly why
um and it's it's the summation of these
many small details
so most of us experience it as a oh i
think that's ugly or i think that's
beautiful or like wow that's elegant but
yeah can't break it down
you mentioned something in passing like
you can train yourself in this though
yeah you can train yourself i think
you can make yourself
pay attention to to why
um you're essentially to bring the
subconscious awareness into conscious
awareness
god i wish i could do that how do you do
that
just just pay really close attention
almost like a meditation on the object
and trying to find the details like why
do i not like this is that what yeah
just look look closely and carefully
lesson number two avoid distractions
with bill gates there's no doubt that
the antitrust lawsuit was bad for
microsoft and
it
we would have been more focused on
creating the uh
phone operating system and so instead of
using android today you would be using
windows mobile if it hadn't been for the
honor trust case
uh microsoft would go oh we were so
close we we you know i was just too
distracted i screwed that up uh because
of the distraction and you know we were
just three months too late with the
release that motorola would have used on
a phone uh
so yes uh it's a winner take all game
that is for sure that you know now
nobody here's ever heard of windows
mobile uh but oh well
and i wouldn't uh
well that's a few hundred billion here
or there uh
i wouldn't have retired as soon and that
one is less you know i am disappointed
that windows mobile didn't succeed but
in terms of
uh my own life
you know even though it was a very
painful thing because i got very
personally involved in the defense of
the company the fact that i retired
earlier probably net was good for me
because i got down the learning curve on
the foundation i got to partner with
melinda in the early days of the
foundation
and you know i don't have a life where
i'm allowed to complain uh because
basically you know only 99 of things
have worked out very very well lesson
number three focus on customer service
with jeff bezos i believe that
the
primary success factor for amazon.com
has been an obsession over the customer
and a focus on customer service this is
clearly important in any business but
especially important online and the
reason for this
is that word of mouth is incredibly
powerful online
if you make a customer unhappy on the
internet they won't tell five friends
they will tell five thousand friends on
usnet news groups and list serves and so
on
likewise of course if you can make a
customer happy by meeting or exceeding
their expectations they can also tell
five thousand people and therefore you
know be evangelists for you they can use
the internet as a megaphone
so it's very important to do the things
that you actually are going to claim to
do and
what this means basically is the balance
of power has shifted away from the
merchant and toward the consumer which
is a great thing i think for everybody
involved it's even great for the
merchant as long as the merchant
realizes it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four have a vision
with oprah winfrey i managed to get here
stedman and i have
absolutely uh differing philosophies
because he um teaches
the idea of he has a book called um not
yeah what is a book called
the book is called you can make it
happen nine steps to success and he's
always um talking to me about cr having
a vision that would with no vision that
people perish and i always say i don't
have a vision i don't have a vision to
get here to where i am my vision was of
surrendering to what i believe was god's
vision for me and i always say god can
dream a bigger dream for you that you
can dream for yourself i now believe
that i need a vision i think stedman is
finally right
that uh in order to continue to move
forward that i need to develop a vision
for myself and um
one of my big goals is to use this
television show as a forum and a
catalyst for change in people's lives
that's one of them yes the other is to
move out into the world in a more um
uh
impactful global format
to help women and children across the
globe without education the people
perish without education
nobody will be able to survive without
education women cannot overcome poverty
will not be able to learn to take care
of themselves will not be able to move
forward on the planet so i want to use
my life and this television show to
continue to do that lesson number five
keep moving forward with richard branson
i honestly just don't think about
mistakes but let me see if i can try i
mean i i just like to if i make a
mistake i put it behind me and i just
move move move forward but
um
but
um
but uh
you know and and you know yes i've you
know i mean there have been you know
music musical bands that i've missed
trying to sign like dars straights um
uh you know there have been companies
that have fallen flat in their face like
virgin kohler
um
uh
you know but
uh uh
you know but
you know that's just part of that's just
part of um
uh you know being an entrepreneur you
you're gonna have these things happening
all the time so i don't really see them
as mistakes they're just um you know
they're just
uh
you know if you're an entrepreneur
you know that some things are not gonna
go right something isn't gonna go right
lesson number six expose yourself to new
things with mark cuban the same thing i
told myself the same thing i tell
everybody
one you're 21 22 23 years old right you
don't have to figure it out right now
don't try
right you spend all this money
sorry
um
paying to learn now it's your chance to
get paid to learn
you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn
and start to be exposed to different
ideas and now it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago
you know it was like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for ibm or general motors
and get a pension those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james you know
where you're always out there and can go
find a better situation for yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
umeki um
um
you know what was how bad could it be i
would lose my motel sixth towel you know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah i understand there's
pressure from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect you can
learn at that job and you guys have the
pedigree you have the brains you have
the initiative to go out and try the
next job you know
you know the good news is the economy is
good enough that it may not be perfect
but you can go job to job don't look for
the perfect answer just look to get the
experience look to learn because all
these different exposures all the
different things you learn learning how
to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juice you for for something
that you love because once you find
something you love to do
that's when the magic happens
because when you're when you're able to
find something you love to do then you
can start work focusing on how can i be
great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know play with
technology and try to do things first
you know whatever it is that you find
about yourself then you can try to be
great at it and it's rare when people
quit things they're great at
you know and so trying those things so
that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things and lesson number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is fix your multiplier with
grant cardone tell us a bit more about
the book that you've brought with you oh
that's an actual man this absolutely
this is the book that everybody knows
about where did that cover 10x
this this was after the collapse
i was working hard
and i kept telling elena what am i doing
wrong
i think a lot of people have this
conversation like what am i doing wrong
i'm working hard
i'm take care of my customers
i'm fair to everybody and i can't get
ahead why can't i get my break i'm a
talented guy
i'm working hard i'm talented i'm
working hard i'm tired like it was like
this like and i cannot get i can't punch
through
and then i saw a lot of people that were
less talented
not taking care of their customers
didn't have as good a product that we're
just
flying
and so i sat down every book i've ever
written except for one
was about
me trying to solve a problem for me and
the 10x rule i didn't know it was going
to be the 10x rule when i finished it
until until i finished it
it was about hey why am i working so
hard not getting ahead and the whole the
premise of this book is my
my multiplier was broken i wasn't
multiplying i was adding
i was doing a little bit more i was
never doing a lot more
i was never doing enough more
to to expand so that i wasn't a slave to
my business now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you watch a video and
just get motivated the science says you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through on your goals that's not good
enough no not for you believe nation we
got to do something but when you write
it down and you create a specific plan
of action for the next week that number
jumps to 91 chance of you following
through and when you commit to somebody
else like leaving a comment on this
video it jumps to 95 percent you need to
follow through on your goals so what was
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your specific plan of action
for the next week put it down in the
comments below so i can celebrate you
like any entrepreneur
when you start a business
you start to worry and people around you
worry much more than you do
when i start alibaba my parents worry my
wife worry my friends were in my
teacher's world my students where
everybody worry and they worry about a
lot of things the only thing that i
worry
is that
i should not disappoint the people who
believe in me
and when we study the alibaba
we have a lot of things people worry you
know when we study alibaba say hey
you don't have a payment you don't have
a trust people do not believe in online
they believe in face to face
meeting and government does not support
internet nobody supported e-commerce how
could you do it
i think
as an entrepreneur
if everything is ready
that does not need you
because nothing is ready that needs
entrepreneurship for counterfeit things
of course
there are lot
at the beginning
but you have to fix it
so in the past 15 years we spend a lot
of time because you have to making sure
the customer feels safe
happy
the brand if you're happy
your reputation is the repetition your
reputation is the best otherwise the
people say i sell on the site and my
things were copied and stolen
so we
using a lot of ways to do that today
more than a hundred thousand
brands
partner with us if you take a look at
life you can have your glasses they say
half empty or half full it's how you
look at it now i've been homeless twice
when you are down
first time was 22 years old and i had a
child homeless with a kid you know he
was a couple years old which would be
interesting because most people see you
now in this multi-billion dollar
situation they would never believe that
at 22. you were homeless with a kid i
mean it didn't look like the trajectory
was heading here right
yeah but when you're down and out and
you're that far down and you've got a
kid and you're kicked out of your place
because rents do you don't have the
money and your wife took off with
everything
everything yeah just little kids wow
anyways we were just too young to get
married uh so you know how to make it
now when you're that low
found a friend of mine who's a blue
singer said when you get down so low and
you look up all you could see is an edge
right when you're that low you could
only go up true so instead of you have a
choice you could sit around and blame
what happened to you on everybody else
which is usually what people do or say
hey that's how things turned out now i'm
going to turn things around you were
just a college dropout you were very
young looking did you get taken
seriously by businessmen who are much
older for some people that youth
uh
and
geekiness uh
it's like hey
should we trust them you know that's so
weird we've never seen something like
that before so yes we had to fight for
acceptance i couldn't rent cars
so i had to take cabs around because i
was too young and you know probably some
people were a little tough but
then as as we got a little bit of
success
people were fascinated by this deep
belief we had in in software so i get
that question all the time so what
industry should i look at i can tell i
can tell you all about artificial
intelligence computer vision
personalized medicine
but then what right
and so the and maybe you're an expert in
one of those fields and you can go for
it but what i tend to try to tell people
in terms of what does it take to be
successful
find something you love to do and then
be great at it
not average
not marginal
not good enough but if you can be great
at it be great at it if you are the the
greatest videographer
in the history of videographers
people don't care about cell phones
what is it that
you can do
that makes them know that what you the
way you do it is special
and if you can do that and convey it
then you'll be fine if you're not sure
then
you know
you've got it you've got to decide
whether you want to stay on your own get
you know be a contractor or go work for
somebody
you know it just depends you know and
let me add one other thing
i i crushed myself
um
and like my brothers didn't they they
took a completely different path and
they were looking just nine to five at
yada yada not everybody's got to be an
entrepreneur and so if you if you've got
it in your blood and that's what you
want to do then find a way to be great
and if not you know you'll figure it out
you'll find something else how do i
define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not going to stand up here and tell
you that it's not about money because
money is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
[Applause]
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money
and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich as you
look back on your career in the space
industry what has been the most
surprising or unexpected challenge that
you faced and along those lines if you
were to go back in time and talk to your
20 year old self would you do anything
differently
go back in time
to your 20 year old self
i mean i think i'd if i could i think it
would make
far fewer mistakes obviously if i could
go
like here's a list of all the dumb
things you're about to do please do not
do them
yeah wouldn't we be a very long list and
like
here let me
write it down or something you know
um
i mean it's hindsight's 2020. so it's
hard to say
i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i had a lot count
honestly
um
i mean some of these things i just wish
i'd like that like that's a
simple sort of mantra
management by rhyming i mean it worked
for homer okay
um
the management by rhyming is
the thing i was saying like if but if
the schedule is long the design is wrong
we've overcomplicated the design many
times
[Music]
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design
um
with the acid test being
how long will it take to
for this to fly
and if it's going to take a long time
don't do it do something else one part
that i'm always um
very focused on is sort of the structure
of these companies and how how well are
people aligned and so you can
and making sure that people are you know
aligned properly not just that they say
i think this is sort of a very a very
legal kind of a framework to think about
what are people's incentives you know
are they going to be lined or not and i
think you want to both have formal
alignment where you set the structure
right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to work together
well in one one way or another um
and i think that somehow tends to get
obscured in all these other ways um you
know there's always a there's always a
uh there's always a
prehistory question i like to ask
founders of of companies which is um
how did you uh how did you um meet
what's the prehistory of the company
before you got started um i find that to
be really instructive a set of questions
to ask a bad answer is something like
you know we met a week ago
at a social networking function at a
business networking function we decided
to start a company because we both
wanted to be entrepreneurs
um you know that's like saying i married
the first person i met at the slot
machines in las vegas and you might hit
the jackpot but it's probably a really
bad idea um and a much better answer is
you know we've been talking about this
for a long time you know maybe
one of us is more on the tech side the
other one's more on the business side we
have these sort of complementary skills
and and so i think this question of um
alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important is there any daily
disciplines that you have in your life
daily routines that you would attribute
to your success
uh
yeah i try to beat the sun up
i write my goals down every day
and i try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i i
created a lifestyle where where some
things are taking care for me that that
that um
most people don't have that that option
you know somebody drives the kids to
school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me but
i live two two minutes from my office
so when i bounce out of here i gotta go
do a live a live stream on real estate
but but uh
yeah that's the first three things if i
can get that done in the morning man i
know i'm gonna have a good day yeah
pretty simple beat the sun up make sure
you write down your goals yeah make sure
you take care of yourself get the blood
flow and get the heart pumping yeah and
it goes down fresh a new unit like in a
new unit of time like i ran down today
like i had never written them down
before nice
yeah
that's um so so so simple on the outside
but so many people won't do
those
three
i dare i dare everybody listening here
to try to do it for 30 days in a row see
if you could even make seven i always
thought we would fail so this is oh it's
all upside down you know i thought maybe
we had a 10 chance of reaching orbit
starting out so
then
uh
if people thought
when we started spacex they said oh
you're going to fail
so i agree i think we probably will fail
yeah it's worth trying anyway
yeah
yeah how's that for honesty huh yeah
this this i said i'd lose like
you know lose all the money from paypal
i was like well you're probably right
you know and we're almost there we first
three launches the falcon one didn't
work then the fourth one we scraped
together some parts and
then that one worked and if that one
hadn't worked
would have been that would have been it
for us so
um
i really believe in the future of space
and and i think it's important that we
become a space prank civilization
and and not be out there among the stars
and i think that's one of the things
that
you know makes people excited about the
future and
we want the things that are in science
fiction
novels and movies not to be science
fiction forever we want to be real one
day your stock at one point i think went
to 100 but then it went down to six or
something like that at the peak of the
internet bubble our stock peaked
somewhere around 113 dollars
and then after the internet bubble uh
you know busted open our stock went down
to six it went from 113 to six in less
than a year so my annual shareholder
that year starts with a one word
sentence and that one word sentence is
the word ouch
so
most of those internet companies of the
dot com era are out of business
yeah you survived what was that that
made you to survive and virtually the
rest of them are gone um i it's very
that whole period is very interesting
because the stock is not the company and
the company is not the stock and so as i
watched the stock fall
from 113 to six i was also watching all
of our internal business metrics number
of customers profit per unit
you know
everything you can imagine defects etc
every single thing about the business
was getting better and fast and so as
the stock price was going the wrong way
everything inside the company was going
the right way and um
uh
i you know so i wasn't we didn't need to
go back to capital markets we didn't
need more money the only reason you know
a financial
bust like the internet bubble bursting
is it makes it really hard to raise
money but you know we already had the
money we needed so we just needed to
continue to progress a lot of startups
complained that they never get the money
from banks
never get money from the other venture
capitalists
well rejected by banks
rejected by your venture capital is very
normal
you got money from these guys not normal
why people want to help you
right
there's no reason people help you
you get help because
you earn the credit
you earn the repetition
so
borrow money from your friends
families that's the sec first step
that's everybody if you cannot even
borrow money from your friends or
relatives you gotta have a problem
nobody trusts you
right
so i heard you bottle through two
thousand one thousand dollars that's
good that that means
you
have
this trust
from those people that around you at
least you got somebody you will
move in the direction of the people that
you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh
you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse
i can't overemphasize how important that
is and you're right the friends you have
uh
they will form you as you go
through life and
uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but have them be
people that you admire as well as like
them we have a culture that's very
focused on um being very focused on what
we're building
so focus is a really important part of
it but it wasn't at google for a long
time now it seems to be in vogue so they
may be saying you know this the focus is
better but so
but at the same time we want to make
sure that everyone can come and and add
their ideas i mean some of the best
ideas throughout the the company's
evolution
they have just been from just places all
throughout the company whether it's an
engineer or you know someone on the the
customer support team or just different
uh just different areas around the
company so we've always had these
hackathons right that are basically time
that we allocate
that the only rules that you don't work
on what you work on the rest of the time
and it's basically an incubator for
people to prototype different ideas much
in the spirit of how facebook got
founded originally
the idea that you can build anything
good in a day or a couple of days right
and get a version of that running um so
you get it running you then test it
internally yeah and then we can see and
that helps us shape the roadmap and what
we want to do in the future but
we also have a culture where we want to
stay very focused and we don't want to
run with a lot of projects that we don't
expect to launch right so um so we want
to get a lot of ideas help have those
ideas shape where we want to go and then
execute in a very focused way on the
stuff that we're going to do but i mean
our culture i mean we have a few values
that are really important to us and one
which i talked about before is just
moving fast right the whole company is
really optimized around someone joining
being able to
build something very quickly be able to
launch it quickly
iterate very quickly on that on an
individual level i think it is always uh
it's always really good if if there's
something that you're incredibly
passionate about and um and just sort of
are fine to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the
one of the the the resolutions i came up
with um a number of years ago was to
always uh um value substance over status
substance over prestige um
and uh you know if i sort of was giving
my younger self advice on what to what
to do or how to how to think about um
your when's one's life i you know i
probably i think i you know um
i probably would still go to stanford
um you know i i might still go to law
school um but i'd ask i'd ask sort of
i'd ask a lot more questions why why i
was doing these things and i think uh i
think if i was honest about it
too much of it was driven by
um by prestige and status and not quite
enough about um really the substance of
uh of trying to learn things and you
know i had sort of this i sort of think
of it as this sort of crazy rolling
quarter life crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm where you know
from the outside everybody wanted to get
in from the inside everybody wanted to
get out um you know after i lasted seven
months and three days and after uh
um and uh when i when i when i left one
of the people down the hall said you
know it's so reassuring to see you leave
peter i had no idea it was possible to
escape from alcatraz which which again
uh and you know and again i and all you
had to do was go through the front door
but our identity um people's identities
get so wrapped up and um the things they
compete for that it was inconceivable
for people to actually do that and and
then the question was you know well how
had i ended up there why had i not
thought about that more and i think it
was
that i had taken too many of these
shortcuts of valuing sort of what was
prestigious what was conventional over
what i uh what i really wanted to do so
i think i think always substance over
status when you get a 1 000 on your
s.a.t
i probably got like a 980 i've convinced
myself that i broke a thousand
creativity becomes a survival skill it's
a necessity to get into the door to
interview to sell everything for me
revolved around creativity so one day at
the recording studio i walk in and
there's a cassette sitting on the music
board
and it's the cassette that changed my
life
the cassette was by an artist a rap
pioneer named dana dane dana was a
brooklyn-born artist his first album was
one of my favorite albums and this was
an advanced copy in the late 80s that
nobody
nobody had sitting there i wanted to
listen to it so i asked the engineer if
i could borrow the cassette and i would
bring the cassette back after i listened
to it he said sure
a couple of days later i'm on my way to
los angeles to visit a friend i'm
listening to it in my sony walkman if
anyone remembers those sony walkman yeah
and when i'm on the plane i read that
the owner of delicious finals favorite
artist this is a big label tone lok and
young his favorite artist is dana dane
so when i land in california i cold
called delicious vinyl i get all the way
up to the assistant of this guy she has
no idea what i'm talking about i'm
talking very fast like a new yorker i
have dana's tape i know mike's a fan of
daina
she puts me on hold
she comes back two minutes later and she
says dana
if you can be here at two o'clock mike
ross would love to meet you
dana will be there at two o'clock
two o'clock comes the dana's a
brooklyn-born guy like i said
african-american goldtooth
not me
i pushed the
now a good friend of mine though
pushed the button they said i said hey
i'm dana here from micros oh
mike is expecting you dana come right in
i walk in they escort me into the office
loc's record young's record he's got
this funky candle going they sit me down
i'm sitting there i'm waiting no idea
what's going to happen in walks
mike ross
and says to me not as politely who in
the world are you
there's a famous quote by harry truman
if you can't convince them
confuse them
it works so far
so i start saying oh i work at the same
studio as dana i know you're a fan of
dana he must be late he has an advanced
tape
can i put in my cassette that i did at
dana studio you have a cassette what do
you do
i wrap
huh put it in
put in my cassette and he says the four
words that every artist struggling
artist wants to hear
who's your lawyer
i don't have a lawyer i have a dad so i
give him my dad's number my dad owns a
plumbing
my dad owns a plumbing supply house in
minneola
i call my father when we leave i said
dad i think i just got a record deal if
someone calls you
we got our foot in the door we're gonna
figure the rest out later get all the
documents
that started a journey of getting my
foot in the door
and figuring it out later a key thing in
creativity starting the process trusting
the process and letting it evolve
because if you don't get your foot in
the door if you don't start
nothing happens i did it with a company
called marquee jet we sold it to warren
buffett i did it with our company's eco
coconut water we sold it to coca-cola i
kind of knew deep down inside like okay
i'm created
for more in the sense of like i have
more to give and and more to create
um and more to serve and more to see
and i always kind of knew it um and i
went through this really life-long
journey though of like
like like knowing i i was kind of
created for more but doubting it anyway
and
kind of my whole life actually and maybe
a lot of people out there may be in the
same spot and it's kind of why i wrote
the book because i feel like
while it's my story of going from a girl
who didn't believe in herself to like
believing in herself and not not
trusting herself to learning actually
how to kind of like break through all
the self-doubt and hear that inner voice
and like and trust it
um go from doubting i'm enough to really
on that journey of knowing i'm enough
the first set of schools that we
launched at after harvard were schools
that had other kind of school specific
social networks so i think it was
stanford had something um colombia had
something
and i think yale had something so i
think why did you choose ones that had
school specific social networks because
i wanted to competitors well i wanted to
go to the schools i thought would be the
hardest for us to succeed at because i
knew that if we had a product that was
better than everything else that other
students were making at other colleges
then it would be worth investing in and
putting putting time into but i didn't
want to just kind of
like get into a project where there
would end up being this huge legacy of
maintaining it if ultimately there were
just going to be different things that
were as good as it the habits you
develop and and i go back the other
thing is have the right heroes i mean
i've always been lucky in that respect
and
if you know if you the people you look
up to
are going to form your vision of what
the world you know how you want to be in
later life and the one
well i'll give you two pieces of advice
i invest as much in myself as you can i
mean you're your own biggest asset by
far i mean you've got you've got all
kinds of potential all the people in
this room you know you're lucky to be in
this country gotten a good education
but
most people go through life using up a
very very small part of their potential
and so anything you do that invests in
yourself uh
is that's the best investment you can
possibly make i cold called neiman sachs
nordstrom bloomingdale's qvc i was out
on the road and i think a lot of
entrepreneurs make the mistake they
think once you get the order you're
golden and that couldn't be any farther
from the truth once you get the order
that's when the real work starts i was
absolutely determined to ensure my own
success and i think that's what it takes
i didn't want my success to be
contingent on anyone else having to sell
this so i hit the ground running and i
went from department store to department
store and i would do morning rallies at
the store where i would gather people
around well the store manager said sarah
you know you can do it with the hosiery
associates well i'd travel all the way
to arizona and there'd be three hosiery
associates so i quickly was like i gotta
get the whole store at this morning
rally so i would go into the entrance
before the store opened like a neiman's
or saks or a bloomingdale's and i would
run around and introduce myself to every
employee setting up their station i'd
say hi i'm sarah and i would try to
convince them that it would be worth
their time to come see my morning
meeting and i got everybody there i had
taken the oprah clip and the a little
bit of local press i'd i'd received and
put it on a video and
did that in my morning rally
and it was such an important thing that
i was doing i inadvertently was building
a sales force that wasn't on my payroll
and they all across the country became
my biggest advocates for the product and
started selling it on behalf of spanx
and me we are
can we be
let's take china and india very
separately so
we are winning in india very very
well um we have an amazing leader there
a guy named ahmet who has been in amazon
for 15 years and
you know here in the us they moved back
to india four or five years ago to start
amazon india
and that team is
is doing well they have passed flipkart
they are the leader in india now
so that is
similar to japan germany
uh the uk france those countries
are you know
very in china the leader is jd
and uh we have we are totally adapting
our strategy in china we cannot
run our normal playbook in china it has
to be specialized and different so we're
doing that what would you say is the
best advice that you could give other
people from what you learned about
making their first million bucks so say
somebody's making six figures scaling up
and that's just do the math you know
what's what's first of all do you want
to make a million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
percent difference between those two
questions right so specificity and the
goal you want to make everybody's
everybody watching is going to make a
million dollars i mean if you live
25 years you're going to make a million
dollars 25 times 40 000 bucks bang you
made a million dollars if that's your
goal so this is what i talked about in
the 10x rule the goals people are
setting
are incorrect and that's why people give
up on their goals because
i know so many guys that hit a million
dollars
like i've had so many people come to me
and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice
yeah it got comfortable almost yeah a
lot of guys in network marketing tell me
this like i was in network marketing i
became a million dollar producer
just lost it because the goal was wrong
the goal was wrong first of all it
wasn't your goal
anybody's got a million dollar target
it's not your goal you adopted this goal
this idea from somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
the chance is a number ending in zero is
almost mathematical what a great point
what a great point so it's a lazy
concept you just adopted somebody else's
idea i want to be a millionaire would do
you have even done the math do the math
on a million dollars it's no money this
is what people
they they like god hate grant
because your target was a million
you're struggling making 200. you think
a million is impossible
you don't want me to tell you the truth
and the truth is it is no money as soon
as you get it i read the book the
millionaire next door almost everybody
read that book back in the 90s
it was the best book for me
because it taught me
i don't want to be a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck
i don't want a ford truck man
right i got to buy a ford truck a used
ford truck f-150
so one day i could be a millionaire yeah
and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack to my office every
day
not drink coffee at the shop
in order to be a millionaire well the
reason i knew that was not good for me
was because my dad died at 52
with a little bit of money
and i'm like i don't want to die
with money when i'm old
i want to have enough money
and that that undid everything for me i
want financial freedom i don't want to
hit a quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on what their
spending is or what their apartment cost
or what the mortgage is rather or what
their kids need rather than i want
freedom i don't want financial literacy
i want financial freedom
you know so i hear people say oh we need
to teach financial literacy no you need
to teach financial freedom the
possibility of it what would i need how
much you know this whole cash flow thing
that i talk about all the time cash flow
is the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number we
should always measure
the good impacts and the bad impacts of
the stuff we have
you know certainly
whenever a new technology comes along
there's a lot of fear about what's going
to do
you know when the printing press came
along
there was a great fear that people would
just read books and not go out and seek
you know real experiences and and
you know i tried that when i was a kid
just reading books and you know maybe
i'd be more rounded if there hadn't been
books
around so i you know i think it's hard i
don't i haven't seen any evidence of any
significance that socialization
has really broken down in some bad way
you know i know that
you know with skype now
i meet my daughter's
boyfriend's parents uh when i walk into
her bedroom uh and there they are on on
skype so socialization is changing
but i don't think
i'm not sure you can really say that
there's a a negative vector there and
there's so many positive vectors about
if you're curious and you want to learn
something you know i was young and i'd
ask a question about hey what's
fertilizer you know if the world book
didn't have it
i i wasn't going to get the answer now
of course you can go online watch videos
and and
you know my children are always asking
questions where if i don't know the
answer we just go and it's actually kind
of fun to learn it together so i'd say
on balance
uh you know i think we're quite quite
far ahead
you know there are some things about
privacy you know maybe misuse of overuse
of pornography you know letting your
kids play too many video games so you
have to set a quota just like
i had to have a quota for how much i was
allowed to read
but uh and i think overwhelmingly
we've got mostly positive things
including the opportunity ahead of us of
how the tool gets used in mainstream
education can you take me back and tell
me how you've done this larry you're
you're the godfather of technology you
founded this company you're still
thriving you're still coming with all
these innovation things and i could see
how passionate you are you're beating
everybody um
and you came from such humble beginnings
grew up on the south side of chicago
dropped out of college now you have
collections of cars jets private homes
owning the island of of lanai
tell me how you did it
well i think i think my favorite line is
i had all the disadvantages necessary
for success
you know uh
when you're raised on the south side of
chicago you probably want to move
someplace nicer
and
i think if it doesn't kill you and makes
you stronger so
i've always been very ambitious i've
always been very curious
uh
i would you know
moved to silicon valley right out of
right after i dropped out of college and
got a job as a computer program i
learned how to program when i was in
college and i got a job as a computer
programmer and bummed around yosemite
valley teaching rock climbing
and and um and
leading river river river trips uh
during my early twenties but um the way
i supported myself was as a computer
programmer
uh
and i got involved with more and more
interesting and complicated
uh computer projects and decided to
start my own company there's nothing
that ai won't impact as big as the um so
bit having been around a while i saw the
impact of pcs then i saw the impact of
local area networks then i saw the
impact of wide area networks then i saw
the impact of the internet then i saw
the impact of mobile then i saw the
impact of wireless you know now i'm
seeing the impact of of artificial
intelligence and it dwarfs any of those
things and if i don't understand how to
apply it to my businesses i mean i
remember selling pcs and software and
walking in saying you don't need to use
that pen and paper on a you know on a
notepad or a ledger pad now we're going
to give you a spreadsheet and by the way
here's a here's a spreadsheet that cost
495 dollars and i had to pay to go get
trained on how to sell it which is crazy
now when you think about it but then we
said okay now you can play what if then
we said you can connect these pcs unless
i understood the technology how was i
going to explain it how was i going to
understand it unless i understand it now
how am i going to invest in it
you know then i got to go trust somebody
who says oh yeah i know ai and maybe
they do maybe they don't and it's really
easy just to have just the okay so you
figure it out that's just not my style
so you're building a base of knowledge
and then you think that at some point
it's going to pay dividends and trades
right i mean if you truly believe ai is
going to change everything how are you
going to understand what people are
doing to change everything unless you at
least have a foundational understanding
of it now i'm not going to build a
million layer neural network and try to
change the world and i'm not going to
show you i'm not going to write a
research paper and saying here's how why
the lottery ticket approach works and
you can build smaller neural networks
with less data um and be more you know
resource efficient but i can read that
stuff and understand that when somebody
says okay we're building this project
and we need this size data set or this
size data set we need this amount of
resources i can ask questions and
understand the answers how did you get
through like tactically to a sale in the
encyclopedia world like people don't
want to hear from you so like how do you
overcome that
what a question asked me
the average encyclopedia salesman
lasted three days
i was at it for three and a half years
and the way it worked in those days it
was commission only so the way it worked
is you went for an interview they told
you all you could possibly make off
commission only and we were in training
for three days it was a presentation
that was scripted we'd have to memorize
the whole thing well we got in the field
you remember parts of it you knock on
doors you're not quite sure of yourself
a lot of doors are closed in your face
but what happens after a while you start
getting used to it and you see what you
can say or do
that'll make it better but when you go
back the next day with your other
salespeople what you see what you do
what did i say
uh so let's say knock on 100 door skin
into one give 10 presentations to sell
one book but then when you get better
and better at it through your
experiences and losses along the way
it sharpens you up where all of a sudden
i got to a point where if i gave three
presentations i have no less than one
order commission only but i believe that
i could do that i believe that colleges
with the best set of books because a
high school student could read it it
wasn't like a college manual you had to
read and i was doing something good for
somebody so you have to believe that
what you're doing is good is going to
benefit somebody and you learn as you go
okay do i look someone in the eye see a
lot of people know these things look
someone in the eye
all too often people say it's hard to
look someone in the eye because you feel
uncomfortable of course you do they're
not on the same wavelength you're on or
the same frequency so what do you do how
do you overcome that you learn these
things along the way you look them right
between the eyes or their eyebrows looks
like you're looking over the eye
i've been working on a book for a couple
of years with some of these tips and
it's not ready yet maybe next year it'll
be ready but uh there's all these things
and of course smile smile is the most
wonderful thing god gave us and you
don't smile when you first talk to
somebody you smile before you knock on
their door
and if your day sucks you fake it
hi how you doing so when you smile
everything changes when i think you were
writing the number of days you had on
your wrist or something like that i
stopped doing that why'd you stop i'm
curious um i'm just so aware of it now
you know um
uh it was starting to freak my wife out
a little bit uh it's a little depressing
but for me it's not depressing
it's like you know
i think people's relationship with time
we talk about relationships with humans
how's your relationship with your kids
how your relationship with your wife you
know your dad or your parents but we
never talk about a relationship with
money and time
and the relation your relationship with
time is such a key component
of your life because when you get caught
in a routine
time goes so quickly when you understand
that there are maybe only 28 summers
left and if you want to truly you know
get as much out of experientially out of
life it just creates a tremendous amount
of urgency
so
and the fear goes away
because you're like
and nobody on the planet like everybody
no one's going to be here in 100 years
do i care what he thinks that like he's
not we're not going to be here in 100
years so why would i take the chance
and it's just i don't know it's just so
i stopped writing it because i'm so
aware of it there's not a day that goes
by when my head hits the pillow where i
don't say to myself like you know did i
maximize the day and am i and you know
am i aware of
my mortality and it might sound
depressing but it's it's not for me it's
um it's thrilling
it's thrilling so how is turning 50
affecting the way that you think i'm
super curious
just realizing that like it went so fast
and realizing that there's so much that
i want to do and being aware
that your 70s are a different decade
than your 40s and 50s
then you have 20
years left
and when you really put it in
perspective
of how many weekends there are you know
there's only 52 weekends and you start
to look at it like that you're like
i'm gonna be 80 in 30 years
scary
you know i got kids it's scary because
there's a lot i want to do i feel like i
haven't done anything compared to what i
what i want to do
and the opportunities
so
you know it just how do you manage your
time i never thought like that i'm
finally live forever
and um you know i'm bulletproof and all
that stuff and i'm not and when you turn
50 it happens
friends get sick you know
let me give you an example of of just
how it's affected me and how even the
monastery and this whole notion of time
which we've been talking it's been a
theme of this conversation
but like um are your parents alive yeah
how old are your parents feeling like
70. okay and where do they live
in different parts of washington state
okay do you see them yeah pretty often
once to three times a year okay so let's
say they live to be 78 which is the i
hope they don't well let's say that they
they live to the average age so you see
him one you said once to three times
yeah okay
no you don't it means you're going to
see him 16. if you see him twice a year
you can see him 16 more times
when you look at it that way
you're like what
you don't have
eight years with them
you have 16 times with them
and that's the shift in my life and
that's the way i look at things
that's a fundamental shift in the way
that i looked at
situations
six months ago
and it's created an urgency it's created
um
a need to just like not put stuff off
and to recognize like what's on your
list of things that you want to do
throughout my 20s i continued
experimenting trying different things
racing bikes and boats and constantly
changing jobs
it didn't take me long to discover
that the most interesting and rewarding
programming jobs were found at a cluster
of companies located south of stanford
university in north of san jose
silicon valley was in its infancy
i was still in my 20s when i went to
work for my first silicon valley startup
amdahl where we developed the world's
fastest mainframe computer faster than
anything ibm had
next stop was ampex
where we built the world's largest
digital data storage system
then on to precision instruments
where we built an even larger data
storage system this time using lasers
i was the vice president in charge of
software development
it was all
very cutting edge and challenging and
cool
i liked my work most of the time but i
didn't love it
i searched and i searched but i just
could not find a software engineering
job
that i loved as much as i loved sailing
so i tried to create one
i put together a plan to start my own
company
that way i could completely control my
work environment
i would hire the most talented
programmers i knew and we would all work
together
on the most interesting and challenging
software projects
my group my goal was to create the
perfect job
for me
a job i truly loved
i never ex i never expected the company
to grow beyond 50 people you know lisa
when i look back at all the things i've
i've done i made so many mistakes but
when i look back at the things i've done
right it was always when i went with my
gut and and deciding to go into
journalism was one of them because um
like you mentioned in the intro i was i
went to graduate school at columbia and
everyone was getting these high-paying
jobs and you know you pay a lot of money
uh you know for school and then you have
this pressure um to get out and get a
job or to do something with it and the
average salary was 126 000 that year out
of columbia business school and i took a
job for 23 500 um because i went with
what i wanted to do in my gut what i was
passionate about which was you know
other people's stories and i i took a
job in the middle of washington state at
a small market but i learned how to
write and edit and and shoot and film
and everything and just put in the work
to try and build a foundation spanx
started i got to set the stage a little
bit for you there were no self there
were no excuse me blackberries no one
had ever heard of an iphone or an ipod
before i mean the kardashians were in
like the fifth grade
and mapquest was just getting started so
half the time i was on my the computer
in the hotel that i was staying at and
trying to map quest my next location and
it was a really crazy time
as i'm driving all around i you know i'm
thinking to myself
actually i i remember this one time in
chicago i'd spent so much time alone on
the road i did an event at the neiman
marcus outside of evanston i believe it
was at in oakbrook or northbrook and i
spent the whole day promoting lifting up
my pant leg and turning and shaking my
butt for everyone in the entrance and
that's you know i'd been setting up
these tables and moving them farther and
farther out of the hosiery department to
the point where they were in the
entrance of neiman marcus i mean people
would walk and i go hi i'm sarah and i
would flash them my butt and you know i
was trying everything i put donuts on
the table i was like have a donut and
some spanx
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaire entrepreneurs check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there you should just be
yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy